>> TUCKER: BTHE EF THIS
MOH BY LAWHE PUBC IS
QUIR TO BE TD WHAT I
OWS ABOUT O'S.
YESTERDAY SOMNE A THE
PENTAGON GE AN EARLY READN
E RORT TO THE "NEYORK
IN THAT STORY WE LEAEDHE
PENTON CNOT SAY THAT UFO'S
E FROM A DIFFERE SOL
SYST.
T TY CAN'T SAYHEY EN'T
EYAN'T S THEY ARE FROM
CHIN OR RUSA BUT TY CAN'T
SA THEY AREN.
SAY MUST HAVEF ANYTHI. CAN
FOR YEARS, ERSA THE CIAL,
INVEIGATNS AT THE U.S
GOVEMENT INTO UFO'S.
HE'S LT W.
HE A HIS ORGIZATION HAVE
OBTAINED A GOVERNMEN DOCUMENT
TH PROS THEDVAND C-TAC
UFO HAS BEEN TCKED FOR 70
YEARS.THANKSEARCOR COMI
-- TH
MUCHOR COMING ON
WH DSHIS DOCUMEN TT
YOVE OAINED SHOW ?
>> THIWAS DOCUMENT TT WAS
OBTAED THROUGH THEREED OF
DEMONSTRATES WVE H ISES,IF YOU R
O'S,T LST F0 YEAR
SINCE 1950 PROBABLYRLIER,
D THIS IS OFFIAL.S. GOVERNME CO.
THIS ISN'T SEYEWITNESS
REPORT FROM A CIVILI.
THIS I OFFICIAL GOVNMEN
DOCUMENTATIO FRO MILITARY PERSO
LITA BRASS AND WHAT ITAYS
IS, QUITECOMPELLING LOOK,
'VEAD AOT OF MITARY AND
INTEIGENCE EYEWITNSS TO
CLUDE SPECIALENTS, AND
SCIEIST, AND ALL OF THEM ARE
SEEING THESE THIS AORE IMPORTAND
U.S.ILITY CILIES. SENTIVE
AND THIS H BEE OCRRIN
CKER, AGAI SCE 1950,
ACCORDING T OFFICIAL.S.
GOVERNMENTDOCUMENTION.
THINK ABOUT THA FOR A
MINUTE
WH WE TALK AUT THA OTHE
CKDROP OF THI RENT REVELATI THA
GOVEMENT HAS FALLY ADMITD
THAT THIS ISOT SOME ST OF
SECRET.S.TENOLO.
WE, OKAY
THAT'S GREA
WELREADY KW THAT B NOW
THERE IS SE WGLE ROOMO S
YBE IT'S SOME FOR OF
VERSIAL TECHNOGY.
HE'S THEROBL WIT THA THEORY.
WE KNO TT TH RUSSIA,FTER
THE BERLIN WL CAMEOWNHEYSHARED H
.
OR SO THIS NEW ROMANCE BETEN
US AND RUIA, WHERE THEYHARE
WITH US, AND BY THEWAY,HEY
WEREEEIN EXACTLY THE SE
THING INHEIR SKIES TT WE
RUSSIAN.E'RE SET'SOT
SOHENEALL THE ONLY OTHER
COUNY THAT CLD POSSIY B
IT WOU BE CHINA.
LET'LOOK AT THATOR SECOND,
TUCKER BAUSEOU'RE TALKI
ABOUT COUNTRYHAT SOMEHO
R 7 YEARS, HAS KEPT THI
TECHLOGYHAT WAS AT LEAST ATHOUST
IT CRET, WASBLE TO ELOY IT
AGAIT US, ALL THEAY BKN
1950.
BY THE Y,HIS IS THE SAME
COUNTR THASTEALS BILLIS OF
DOLLAR WORTH OF OUR TECHNOLY EA
DA WITH O COUNY.
W, DS THAT MAKE A WHOLE LOT
OF SENSE TO YOU?
>>UCKER: NO.
NO I MEAN,HERE WERE FAMES
IN CHINA 7 YEARS A THERE.
SEEMS TO B SOME CONNECTI, ANECD
OBJECTS AND NUCLE RETORS NUCLEA,
NUCLR-POWERED VECLES
SUARINE AND RSHIPS.
WE DIDT GET NUCAR
TENOLOGY,F COURSE, UNTILHE
1944-1945.OND WLDR,
WEAD AIRPLANES, AN ARMY AIRCOUR
WORL R.
WE THERE SIGHTIS BORE THE
TECHLOGY?
>> THERE WERSIGHNGS BUT
THERE SEED T BE A SIGFICANT
TAKE ONCE WE ENTERED INT THE
WE BEGAN TO SEE A INCREASED
UPTICK RONNAISSANCE OR
SUEILLANCE OF O NLEAR
CHNOLOGY, OUR NLEAR
DELOPMENT, WHETH IS POWER
ORROPULSION OR WEANS SYSTEMSAND.
>> TUCR: THAT'S JUS -- IT'S
AMAZIN
IT A TANTALING GGESTION.I'M NOT
AS IERESTING ASLL.
APPRECTE SEEG U.
>> ALWS A PLEARE.
>> T CRI RATES ARE GOING UP
ARND THE COUNTRY.
YO ALREADY KNO THAT WE HAVE NEW
RATE I AMERICS BIGGEST CITSARE E